you are likely already familiar with the
relationship between multiplication and
division for example we know that three
times six is equal to eighteen
but another way to express that same
relationship is to say all right if 3
times 6 is 18
then if i were to start with 18 and
divide it by 3 that would be equal to 6.
or you could say something like this
that 18
divided by
divided by 6
is equal to
3.
now we're just going to extend this same
relationship between multiplication and
division to expressions that deal with
fractions
so for example
if i were to tell you that 1 4
divided by i'm going to color code it
divided by 2
is equal to 1 8
is equal to 1 8.
how could we express this relationship
but using multiplication
well if 1 4 divided by 2 is equal to 1 8
that means that 1 8 times 2 is equal to
1 4. let me write this down or i could
write it like this i could write that 1
4
is going to be equal to it's going to be
equal to 1 8
times 2
times
2.
and we could do another example
let's say that i were to walk up to you
on the street and i were to tell you
that hey you
42
is equal to
7
7 divided by
1 6. in the future we will learn to
compute things like this but just based
on what you see here how could we
express this same relationship between
42 7 and 1 6 but express it with
multiplication pause this video and
think about that
if 42 is equal to 7 divided by 1 6 that
means that 42 times 1 6 is equal to 7.
so let me write that down this is the
same relationship as saying that 42
times
1 6
1 6
is equal
to
7.
now let's say i walk up to you on the
street and i were to say all right you
i'm telling you that one-fourth
divided by
divided by six
is equal to some number that we will
express as t
so can we rewrite this relationship
between 1 4 6 and t but instead of using
division use multiplication
pause this video and try to think about
it
so if 1 4 divided by 6 is equal to t
based on all of the examples we've just
seen that means that if we were to take
t times 6 we would get 1 4.
so we could write it this way t
times 6
times 6
is going to be equal to 1 4.
if this isn't making sense i really want
you to think about how this relationship
is really just the same relationship we
saw up here
the only new thing here is instead of
always having whole numbers we're having
fractions and representing some of the
numbers with letters